hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live es ist Tag
555 im russischen Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine gegen die gesamte Ukraine
manchmal hilft es sich diese Zahl vor
Augen zu führen um hier im Westen nicht
zu vergessen wie lange dieser brutale
Krieg schon geführt wird wir wollen
heute mit euch auf die aktuelle Lage an
der Front schauen denn in den
vergangenen Tagen hat die Offensive der
Ukraine an Dynamik gewonnen wir wollen
auch über die jüngsten drohenangriffe in
sprechen und live in die Ukraine
schalten welche Auswirkungen könnten
diese Drohnenangriffe haben auf den
Kriegsverlauf das wird heute Thema sein
das Thema nämlich bei uns heute
russlandsverteidigung bröckelt da geht
es also jetzt um den Frontverlauf auch
um die Drohnenangriffe stellt gerne
Fragen per Mail oder kommentiert direkt
im Stream mit bei uns zu Gast wird sein
der Militärexperte Markus KB der gerne
für diese Fragen zur Verfügung steht um
die zu beantworten die Ukraine die setzt
nämlich offenbar immer mehr
ein und zwar nicht nur gegen sondern
eben auch in Russland und auch in Moskau
in anderen russischen Regionen gibt es
Berichte über neue Angriffe wir haben
dazu einen Beitrag vorbereitet von
Christian
Volk dieses Video veröffentlicht der
Gouverneur der russischen Region psorum
kurz nach 23 Uhr die Luftverteidigung
des Militärflughafens habe ein
unbekanntes Objekt abgeschossen hunderte
Kilometer von der ukrainischen Grenze
entfernt eine Anspielung darauf kommt
von Präsident
heute war ein ereignisreicher Tag es gab
einen konferenzanruf mit Vertretern von
Militär und Regierung es ging um die
Front um die Offensive und um die
Reichweite neuer ukrainischer Waffen sie
beträgt 700 km ziel ist eine noch höhere
reichweiteov war offenbar bereits am
Mittwoch Ziel von Drohnenangriffen
Satellitenbilder sollen mehrere
zerstörte Transportmaschinen zeigen seit
Jahresbeginn haben die Angriffe auf
russische Ziele deutlich zugenommen vom
Schwarzen Meer bis nach
Nordwestrussland ein drohenhersteller in
Kiev kurz nach der Invasion hatten sie
hier acht Mitarbeiter mittlerweile sind
es 40 umgerechnet mehrere hundert
Millionen Euro hat die Regierung für die
drohenproduktion in diesem Jahr schon
bereitgestellt wir müssen sehr schnell
sein sie brauchen die drohen jetzt
unsere Jungs unsere
Streitkräfte etwa 15 Drohnen stellen sie
hier jeden Monat her nutzen Sperrholz
Aluminiumrohre Kunststoffe auch sie
bezeichnen sich als Soldaten die das
eigene Land
verteidigen Militärexperte Markus K ist
nun bei uns er lehrt an der Ith Zürich
heute unser Gast hallo schön dass Sie da
sind hallo guten Abend wir haben es eben
gerade gemeinsam in dem Beitrag gehört
die Ukraine setzt immer mehr drohen ein
schon seit Jahresbeginn nicht nur
selbstgebaute auch günstigere
kommerzielle sind die Angriffe gegen
Russland die wir bislang jetzt gesehen
haben sind die erst der Anfang und hat
die Ukraine denn wirklich genügend
drohen um die russische Flugabwehr vor
wirkliche Probleme zu
stellen ja ich denke das hängt davon ab
von welchen Typus Drohne man spricht
also insgesamt sieht Russland jetzt so
langsam was passiert wenn ein Land mit
Drohnen angegriffen wird ne bisher
mussten das nur die Ukrainer erdulden
und nun bekommen die Russen sozusagen
ihr ihr ihre eigene Medizin ein bisschen
ihre bittere Medizin zuus spüren wenn
wir uns das angucken selenski spricht ja
zunächst mal von von Langstrecken ähm
Waffen und die Ukraine hat ja durchaus
Drohnen dieser bauert also z.B die
tupolif 141 über die haben wir mal
letztes Jahr gesprochen dass war die die
damals die Engels Luftwaffenbasis
angegriffen hat und das Problem mit
solchen großen drohen ist natürlich ähm
dass die russische Luftabwehr sie
relativ leicht erkennen und auch
abfangen kann ähm der zweite Typus den
wir gesehen haben in den Beitrag der ist
weitaus gefährlicher und das ist das was
wir so in den letzten 10 Tagen gesehen
haben ähm nämlich eine extreme lowcost
Drohne also hier sehen wir es gerade
eigentlich aus aus Papier aus aus Pappe
oder aus Aluminium und diese Materialien
die werden gezielt gewählt warum weil
sie keine Radarsignatur haben das heißt
also diese diese Materialien
reflektieren das radarsignal nicht das
heißt die sind auf dem klassischen Radar
so gut wie unsichtbar das ist nicht
unbedingt neu im Zweiten Weltkrieg schon
haben die hat die whrmacht und auch die
Royal Airforce mit solchen Trägern
experimentiert also vor allem aus
Aluminium neu ist jetzt aber die
Massenproduktion also solche drohen die
können Sie nicht nur sehr schnell
herstellen sie sind auch billig und wenn
Sie sich jetzt vorstellen dass sowas
großflächig eingesetzt wird gegen
militärische Ziele in Russland also dass
wir nicht mehr das Modell haben eine
einzelne schwere große Drohne fliegt los
sondern ein ganzer Schwarm von
billigdrohnen fliegt los sowas ist von
einer klassischen Luftabwehr eigentlich
nicht mehr aufzuhalten und man muss sich
klar machen in diesem Krieg Drohnen sind
nicht etwa etwas etwas Besonderes oder
oder wertvolles Drohnen sind
verschleißmaterial also so eine typische
Quadcopter Drohne die hält vielleicht
drei bis vier Einsätze durch danach wird
sie entweder abgeschossen oder sie geht
verloren oder sie sie wird vom Gegner
mit elektronischer Kriegführung gestört
und so weiter also sie brauchen laufend
Nachschub und diese Art von billigdohnen
die könnte jetzt tatsächlich ein
gamechanger werden weil sie nämlich die
Produktion extrem dezentralisieren
können die klassische Produktion von
rüstungsg die findet ja in Fabriken
statt also in großen Industrieanlagen
die können Sie sehen auf der Karte
lokalisieren und dann e auch beschießen
das hat ja Russland gemacht im letzten
herbstwinter also versucht die die
ukrainische Rüstungsindustrie zu treffen
diese Art von Drohnen die können Sie
notfalls im Keller im Hobbyraum auch in
freiem Gelände zusammenbauen an
tausenden verschiedenen Orten und sowas
können sie nicht mehr ausschalten das
heißt also nicht nur technologisch
sondern logistisch ist das ein Vorteil
für die Ukraine und ich denke schon dass
sie jetzt die Produktion dieser dieser
lowcost drohen
forieren dazu zu den drohen noch eine
Frage aus dem Stream kommt von User
vevar wie ist es zu werten dass kleine
padrohen so einen Schaden anrichten
können im russischen Hinterland jetzt
formuliert er hier noch da passt doch
was nicht bei den Russen also wie ist
das zu werten dass die so einen Schaden
anrichten
können ja ja es es gibt ja auf Twitter
den berühmten #w Air deffens doing aber
das das ist nicht unbedingt ein Problem
der Russen das ist einfach unglaublich
schwer ein so kleines Objekt das Tief
fliegt und kein Radar signignatur hat
überhaupt zu sehen auf einem klassischen
Radar ein klassisches Radar ist auf
sowas gar nicht ausgelegt
zweiter Punkt
das das Ding ist so lowtech dass es
einfach außer der explosivladung und dem
kleinen Elektromotor überhaupt keine
elektromagnetischen Bauteile
verbaut hat also sprich mit
elektronischen Mitteln sowas zu stören
ist ebenfalls sehr schwer also nehmen
wir sowas wie wie Excalibur oder nehmen
wir Storm Shadow also
äh lang oder Mittelstrecken missers die
mit GPS gelenkt werden oder mit
Infrarot die alle können Sie sehen die
können sie stören mit elektronischer
Kriegführung aber ich denke es ist diese
Kombination aus klein fliegt tief kann
vom Radar nicht gesehen werden und
selbst wenn ihnen 100 Stück verloren
gehen das macht nichts die ist so billig
und so schnell produziert wir schicken
sie halt einfach die nächsten 100 los
das das ist einfach eine eine
asymmetrische Technologie ie die sie mit
der Technologie des 20 Jahrhunderts die
die Russland die wesentlichen hier
einsetzen nicht mehr abfangen können und
das das ist eben das gefährliche danke
für den Moment wir sprechen gleich
weiter mit ihnen bekommen ihre Analyse
über die aktuelle Lage an der Front
wollen jetzt aber erstmal noch auf die
Auswirkung für die Zivilisten in der
Ukraine schauen denn auch heute
natürlich wieder Thema während Russland
sich erst seit geraumer Zeit mit
Angriffen im eigenen Land
auseinandersetzen muss sind Angriffe auf
die Ukraine grausamer Alltag auch letzte
Nacht sind in der zentralukrainischen
stad wiiniza mindestens drei Menschen
bei einem Raketenangriff verletzt worden
immer wieder Angriffe so auch im Süden
unser Reporter h Henner Hebestreit ist
für uns im Süden ist live für uns jetzt
in sapporija zugeschaltet auch dort gibt
es immer wieder Angriffe mit drohen und
Raketen hallo Henner erstmal schön dass
du bei uns
bist schönen guten Abend noch Mainz
Henner so nah an der Front weil das ist
saporija die letzte Großstadt vor der
Front im Süden wächst da aktuell die
Sorge eben in in saorija so an der Front
vor noch heftigeren Angriffen dass das
einfach wieder schlimmer wird jetzt
gerade das spüren wir so nicht es ist so
dass es hier in einer Tour Luftalarm
gibt ich glaube heute waren es
mindestens ein halbes Dutzend oder noch
zwei drei mehr die Sirenen heulen und
sie heulen lange und die Leute nehmen
das mittlerweile auf der Straße so zur
Kenntnis zucken mit den Schultern weil
hier wirklich relativ viel passiert wir
erinnern uns ein paar Wochen her da
wurde hier ein großes Hotel in der Stadt
getroffen da waren auch schon mal
Diplomaten und Journalisten und auch
viele Soldaten abgestiegen ukrainische
Soldaten das Hotel ist schwer beschädigt
wir haben uns das heute morgen noch mal
angeguckt vor einem Jahr haben wir da
ziemlich genau um diese Zeit davor
gestanden und berichtet wie
internationale atomenergieinspektoren
dort abgestiegen waren jetzt ist es eine
reine Trümmerwüste nur mit viel Glück
oder aber dass irgendjemand die Hand
darüber gehalten hat
kam die Rakete erst dann zum Einsatz als
eine sommerchule voller Kinder aus der
Region dort äh ihren Kurs be end hatte
eine halbe Stunde später kam die
Explosion dort man ist hier schon sehr
viel gewöhnt und will auch sehr klar
zeigen wir lassen uns nicht weiter
erschrecken also der letzte große
Einschlag hier in der Stadt liegt jetzt
doch schon ein bisschen zurück aber wie
gesagt die Gefahr durch diese dauernden
Sirenen ist permanent spürbar man weiß
nie kommt jetzt was oder ist es doch
wieder blinder Alarm Daueralarm ein
Dauer Dauerzustand im Alarm und die zu
diesem schrecklichen neuen Alltag in der
Ukraine gehört also AK ell auch dass das
zweite Schuljahr im Krieg heute begonnen
hat der erste Schultag nach den
Sommerferien du warst dabei du warst mit
unterwegs wirst uns gleich berichten
eine Zahl die interessant ist heute
rausgegeben wurde von safe the children
vorher noch 1,7 Millionen Kinder in der
Ukraine das sind mehr als 40% der
Schülerinnen und Schüler die können
nicht mehr normal zur Schule gehen da
findet also online und hybridunterricht
statt du warst heute unterwegs mit
erstkläslern wie war
das das war ganz
überraschend putzig wenn ich das das
Wort gebrauchen darf wir waren in dieser
Schule und hat natürlich auch für die
anderen Kinder der Unterricht begonnen
und da saß dann eine eine eine eine
Lehrerin in einem kleinen Kämmerlein vor
einem Laptop da waren dann ihre ganzen
Schülerinnen und Schüler aufgeführt um
sie herum nur Stofftiere und sie hat von
dort Unterricht gemacht und dann ging
die Sirenen los hat sie ihr Laptop
zugeklappt hat gesagt liebe Kinder geht
zu Hause an einen sicheren Ort und wir
zogen uns dann mit den anwesenden
Lehrerinnen und Lehrern in den Bunker
zurück dann kam wir nach einiger Zeit
wieder raus und da war der ganze Schule
voller Eltern Eltern von Grundschülern
von Erstklässlern die gesagt haben die
waren angezogen als würden sie zur
großen Party zur großen Feier gehen die
haben gesagt wir gehen auf eigene Gefahr
in die Schule wir wollen uns diesen
Festtag für die Kinder von den Russen
nicht nehmen lassen und da waren sie da
und war ein großes ich w schon sagen
fast eine große Party auf dem Schulhof
die Schulleiterin hat die Hände über den
Kopf zusammengeschlagen und hat gesagt
oh Gott das ist alles verboten weil saug
gefährlich
aber die Eltern haben gesagt wir machen
das auf eigene Gefahr und wir wissen wir
riskieren hier unser Leben aber das ist
auch auch unser Leben und das soll
weitergehen das Leben soll weitergehen
danke für deine Eindrücke von heute
Henna hbestreit live aus zorija das
Leben das weitergeht und das ist jetzt
auch wie ein krasser Kontrast hier in
unserer Sendung wir werden jetzt hier
weiter über den Frontverlauf sprechen wo
täglich Menschen verwundet werden und
sterben unweit davon eben sapua diese
Bilder Einschulung für viele Kinder die
dort eben noch Leben genau die diesen
krasse Diskrepanz leben die Menschen
dort ich habe es am Anfang gesagt gesagt
seit
555 Tagen nun kommen wir also ein harter
Bruch zum Frontverlauf zur Analyse
Markus KUB Militärexperte ist uns wieder
zugeschaltet ich habe auch schon gesehen
es gibt viele Fragen von euch ich gehe
sie auch gleich zusammen durch schauen
wir aber eben kurz gemeinsam jetzt mal
auf den Frontverlauf im Süden und Osten
dass wir gemeinsam uns jetzt hier noch
mal ein Bild machen können und dann
natürlich von Markus Kolb auch das
erklärt bekommen bzw er wird es einfach
direkt schon tun wir sprechen über die
Erfolge die es geben soll über die
Erfolge im Süden und Osten wie ist die
aktuelle Lage nehmen Sie uns erst schon
mal mit mhm also die Ukraine ähm hat
einen bedeutenden äh Durchbruch durch
die russischen Linien also genauer
gesagt durch die erste
Verteidigungslinie äh geschafft und das
ist etwas Bedeutendes ähm aus einer
etwas größeren Perspektive und da ist es
ganz sinnvoll sich auf diese Karte mal
kurz zu fokussieren ähm damit klar wird
was ist eigentlich das Ziel des ganzen
das strategische Ziel dieser ganzen
Operation ist nach wie vor die Südfront
zu spalten also die russische Südfront
das heißt also so starken Druck
auszuüben auf die russischen Truppen
dass sie nicht mehr in der Lage sind
ihre Logistik zu koordinieren dadurch
sie entweder zum Rückzug zu zwingen oder
sie aufzureiben indem man sie gegen die
Schwarzmeerküste drückt und wir sehen
hier rabatine also der Ort wo sich diese
Tasche bildet hat da sage ich gleich
noch was dazu aber in der Mitte sehen
wir den togmar und das ist wichtig dass
man den kennt das ist der wichtigste
Knotenpunkt für die ostwestverschiebung
der russischen Logistik das heißt also
wenn die Russen sich entlang bewegen
ihrer Frontlinie dann tun sie das
natürlich hinter ihren
Befestigungsanlagen und verschieben dort
Truppe und Material das heißt also die
Ukraine versucht diese Stadt bzw diesen
Raum zu erreichen und von dort aus dann
die russische Logistik zu unterbinden
und im zweiten Schritt dann weiter
vorzustoßen entweder nach Melitopol oder
an die schwarzmerküste also soweit
soweit der Plan und wenn wir jetzt
hineinschauen vielleicht auf die auf die
zweite Karte genau da sehen wir jetzt
hier ein eine etwas detailliertere
Ansicht also man man muss sich
vorstellen die Ukraine konzentriert hier
die Kräfte um einen signifikanten
durchst
durch die russische Front zu erzielen es
geht also nicht wie viele in der
Vergangenheit immer gesagt haben um um
den hollywoodreifen Durchbruch und Sie
müssen die ganzen Linien überwinden und
und so weiter das ist alles Unsinn diese
Operationsführung die erinnert eher an
klassische Schlachten des Zweiten
Weltkriegs also spricht sie versuchen an
einem bestimmten Punkt einen Durchbruch
zu erzielen ind dem sie starken Druck
ausüben auf den Gegner dadurch eine
Lücke aufzumachen die muss so 5 bis 10
km breit sein und durch diese Lücke
schieben Sie dann das schwere Material
also ihre Reserven durch und die Ukraine
ist jetzt gerade dabei diese Lücke
aufzumachen das ist also ein sehr
gefährlicher Moment für die Russen ich
erkläre kurz vielleicht wie wie sie da
vorgeht wir sehen in der Mitte den Ort
elle watatte und das Problem ist sie
können nicht direkt von robertine aus
dorthin vorstoßen da liegt nämlich so
ein kleiner Hügelzug dazwischen mit dem
Höhenunterschied von ungefähr 50 m und
da läuft auch eine eine grabenlinie
durch das heißt sie versucht es im
Moment zu frankieren also sie geht
östlich nach verbor und
und südwestlich nach novprokivka und
sobald Sie diese beiden Orte erreicht
hat sie steht im Moment Unmittelbar vor
den beiden Orten kann sie diesen kleinen
Hügelzug umgehen und sie können sich
vorstellen die die Bewegung schlägt dann
schlägt dann wieder ein also von berbor
schwenkt sie ein nach
vate und von Nov geht sie direkt südlich
und wir sehen tomar ist das Ziel beider
jetzt haben wir noch folgenden Effekt
die Straße t0408 die verbindet novapivka
mit tokmar und die Straße t0401 die
verbindet D mit Tom das sind die
russischen Nachschublinien an die Front
also die sogenannten groundlines of
communication und über diese Straßen
verschieben die Russen also ihre eigene
Logistik und das heißt die sind weder
vermient noch sind sie besonders
gesperrt also solange die die Ukraine
die russische Artillerie ausschalten
kann weil diese Straßen werden im
Prinzip aus der Ferne kontrolliert also
mit Artillerie ähm dann kann sie
Vorrücken auf diesen Straßen und dann
nimmt das Ganze plötzlich
Geschwindigkeit an das ist typisch für
solche Operationen
am Anfang sieht das alles so so mühsam
aus und es kommt langsam voran so lange
bis sie die gegnerischen Kräfte zur
Überdehnung bringen und dann kollabiert
das ganze Platz dazu muss man muss man
noch etwas wissen nämlich über den
Zustand der der russischen Truppen die
diesen Abschnitt verteidigen vielleicht
können wir gerade die zweite Karte noch
mal eingeblendet sehen mit Sicherheit es
gibt übrigens gleich auch ganz viele
Fragen aus dem Stream an sie ja ja das
das kann ich mir vorstellen ich ich
erkläre nur nur kurz noch die Lage zu
Ende und und dann kann man nicht
bombardieren mit Fragen
dieser dieses ganze Gebiet wird
verteidigt von der 56 russischen Armee
deren zwei Hauptquartiere die stehen so
ungefähr auf der Mitte der Straße also
so zwischen zwischen Tate und tomar bzw
noopivga und toma deren Verbände sind
allerdings nicht mehr voll Kampf
also sprich so nach den Schätzungen die
ich gesehen habe sind sie vielleicht
noch bei 50% Kampffähigkeit was die
Russen im Moment machen ist sie
versuchen diese Kräfte zu stapeln wie
sie das nennen also sie sagen okay aus
aus zwei Kranken kann man einen gesunden
machen indem man sie einfach
hinterinander stapelt das hat bisher in
wbow nicht
funktioniert die Ukraine ist ist relativ
erfolgreich und auch relativ schnell
dorthin vorgerückt und aus dem Grund
verlegen die Russen im Moment die 76
luftlandedivision
in diesen Raum und versuchen dadurch
diesen Vorstoß aufzufangen man muss dazu
wissen das ist eine Eliteeinheit und das
ist auch dieselbe Einheit die in butcha
die Kriegsverbrechen begangen hat die
wurde damals in in butcha stark
dezimiert danach wieder aufgefüllt mit
mobix ist also auch nicht mehr voll
kampffähig ähm und
man man sieht hier auch diesen diesen
typischen Trick der Ukraine sie versucht
so lange Druck aufzubauen an einem Punkt
bis sie die Russen zwingt Kräfte
abzuziehen von anderen Sektoren der
Front und damit diese diese
frontsektoren zu zu
schwächen jetzt hier mal kurz eingreifen
müssen weil wir haben so viele User mit
so vielen Fragen sonst bekommt ein
Ungleichgewicht und zwar möchte der User
Michael Müller wissen weil sie haben
Straßen angesprochen die zwar befahrbar
wären oder zu benutzen wären aber er
fragt sich wie sollten plötzliche
Durchbrüche durch die russischen
Verteidigungsstellung gelingen wenn
alles überall sofort mit sichich Drohnen
aufgeklärt
wird ja gut gut ich meine Aufklärung ist
nicht so sehr ein Thema weil das Gelände
ziemlich vollständig bekannt ist also
sowohl den Russen wie auch den Ukrainern
es geht weniger um Aufklärung also die
beiden Seiten wissen wo was ist also die
Ukrainer kennen ziemlich genau die die
die Position der Gräben und und wer da
drin sitzt und wie viele und die Russen
kennen die ukrainischen
Angriffsoperationen also das hier ist
nicht mehr irgendwie wie soll ich sagen
so eine eine heimliche Operation sowas
wie die rakov isium Operation ja wo sie
unerwartet und plötzlich vorstoßen ähm
sondern das hier ist wirklich headon das
ist Kraft gegen Kraft und es setzt sich
derjenige durch der gewaltsam diesen
Raum und diese Achsen kontrolliert das
Problem bei den Straßen ist ich hab es
vorhin angedeutet ist die Artillerie
also diese Straßen können sie nicht
einfach befahren weil ja also da könnte
man sagen Aufklärung natürlich sehen Sie
alles was sich auf den Straßen bewegt
das Problem ist halt haben sie eine
Artillerie die diese Straßen
kontrolliert im Moment können das die
Russen noch aber äh die ukra wird jetzt
natürlich versuchen die russische
Artillerie im Hinterland auszuschalten
und damit diese Straßen befahrbar zu
machen aber der Punkt ist eben dass es
diese Straßen gibt also spricht dass sie
sich nicht erst endlos durch vermientes
Gelände Vorarbeiten muss sondern dass
sie jetzt die Chance hat dieser dieser
Bewegung eine deutliche Beschleunigung
zu geben und das ist das eigentlich
gefährliche Moment für die Russen sie
haben die Bedeutung tokmx schon
rausgestellt also was eine Eroberung
tokmars bedeuten könnte sich sehe mir
mehrere Fragen hier im Chat die sich
frag würde die Rückeroberung Tom
wirklich alles wenden stimmt es dann
dass die Rückeroberung auch der Krim
gelingen würde also da gerne noch mal
für uns eine Antwort also es geht nicht
so sehr um die Rückeroberung des Ortes
sondern es geht darum dass man von
diesem Ort aus die russische Logistik
sehr effizient unterbinden kann also
südlich von tokmar läuft eine wichtige
Eisenbahnlinie und es verlaufen
ebenfalls mehrere wichtige Landstraßen
hier zusammen ja und man man kann also
sagen tomar ist quasi so eine Art
Wachposten der den ganzen rückwärt tig
en Raum beherrscht bis hin zur
Schwarzmeerküste und ich habe jetzt
vorhin über die 56 Armee gesprochen und
und wie sie ihre Verbände stapelt jetzt
muss man aber auch sehen Sie stapelt
alles was sie hat um diesen Durchbruch
hier aufzufangen das heißt also im
Hinterland steht nichts mehr jedenfalls
keine keine signifikanten Reserven und
das bedeutet eben sobald sie sobald sie
hier diese Logistik abschneiden können
kann dieser Raum von den Russen nicht
mehr kontrolliert werden und damit ist
die Südfront effektiv gespalten das
heißt also wenn sie jetzt sich
vorstellen sie gucken von tokmar aus
westlich also in Richtung der
kalanchakfont wo die Russen am dünnsten
stehen alles was dann da steht zwischen
tokmar und dem Mündungsgebiet des nipro
das kann logistisch nicht mehr versorgt
werden und mit mit der Konsequenz die
müssen sich sofort zurückziehen oder sie
werden aufgerieben und auch wenn sie in
östlicher Richtung schauen
dann ist die Straße frei in Richtung
Melitopol und berdansk und äh von von
anderen Richtungen der Front könnte die
Ukraine dann ebenfalls versuchen auf
berdjansk äh vorzustoßen und das macht
so das gefährliche aus also der Ort
selber ist nicht mal so wichtig den kann
man auch umgehen ähm es geht darum dass
man äh dass man die logistischen Linien
kontrolliert und damit das Gebiet für
die Russen unhaltbar macht und dazu
passt die Frage die ich hier im Stream
gesehen habe wenn das denn gelingt wie
will man die Front seitens der Ukraine
nachhaltig stabilisieren sollte ein
Durchbruch hier wird jetzt genannt
meditopol als große Stadt eben gelingen
ja also frontstabilisieren ist
vielleicht der der falsche Begriff also
es geht zunächst mal darum dass die dass
es der Ukraine gelingt ihre
strategischen Reserven durchzuschieben
durch diese Öffnung also das sind
insbesondere die schweren gepanzerten
Brigaden deren Großteil immer noch nicht
an der Front erschienen ist also sie
können sich vorstellen die stehen im
Hinterland und warten bis jetzt diese
Operation hier möglicherweise ähm das
das Türchen aufmacht durch die sie dann
vorstoßen können äh das das Ziel ist
also nicht ähm klassisch irgendwelche
Städte zurück zu erobern oder zu
besetzen sondern den Russen klar
zumachen wenn ihr euch nicht sofort
zurückzieht dann könnt ihr euch
logistisch nicht mehr versorgen mit der
Konsequenz ihr werdet eingeschlossen und
vernichtet das war genau die gleiche
Überlegung bei der chakov isium
Operation heute vor ziemlich genau einem
Jahr oder auch bei der Rückeroberung äh
von resson das ist immer das gleiche
Motiv man muss den Russen klar machen
dass ihre Position nicht mehr zu halten
ist und ähm was wir in der Vergangenheit
gesehen haben ist jedenfalls sie
reagieren dann relativ rational das
heißt sie bleiben nicht einfach stehen
und lassen sich Zusammenschießen sondern
sie ziehen sich rechtzeitig zurück bevor
das passiert und ich denke das ist auch
hier wieder das Kalkül wenn Sie
melitppel ansprechen das ist die Stadt
mit der mit Abstand größten Partisanen
Aktivität also ich denke da wartet die
Bevölkerung geradezu darauf endlich
loszuschlagen und die russische
Besatzung zu beenden es gibt ein
Kommentar dazu von einem User homestyle
nennt er oder sie Sicht hockmark wird
wenn es mies läuft das zweite Bach Mut
werden und ohne Reserven hat man da
quasi keine Erfolge schreibt der User
würden sie das genauso sehen also der
User ist da sehr kritisch ja nein ich
sehe das nicht so weil es ich sehe
keinen militärischen Grund warum man die
Stadt tokmax selber erobern sollte also
die dieser Häuserkampf von bachmut der
hatte ja etwas fundamental irreales also
auch auf Seiten auf Seiten der Russen
nicht ich denke das hatte vielleicht
mehr propagandistische oder ideologische
Bedeutung ähm aber wenn Sie wenn Sie
einfach neutral und und ganz ganz
unideologisch mal anschauen wie die
Ukraine bisher diesen Kampf geführt hat
ähm dann dann führt sie diesen Kampf
eben nicht äh soll ich sagen mit mit der
klassischen Methode Meter um Meter
Gelände
zurückerobern sondern das das ist ein
Krieg der über über auf Englisch würde
man sagen denial of logistics also über
die die unmöglichmachung von von
militärischen Verschiebungen
funktioniert das ist übrigens ein ein
Element dass die Russen patu nicht
begreifen wollen also Sie sie sehen hier
wirklich verschiedene Arten ähm den den
Krieg zu führen die die aufeinander
treffen und ich bin nach wie vor der
Überzeugung wenn man diesen Krieg
verstehen will dann muss man ihn von der
logistischen Seite her betrachten und
nicht von irgendwelchen geländegewinnen
oder von von irgendwelchen Bildern von
wir wir erobern jetzt die Städte zurück
man muss sich klar machen wie dünn die
Russen hier stehen also wie wie wenig
russische Truppen auf diesem riesigen
Gelände stehen also unter unter normalen
Bedingungen jetzt beispielsweise wie im
Zweiten Weltkrieg könnten sie so ein
Gelände gar nicht halten
und die Perspektive würde ich empfehlen
zu zu a sie sagten wie dünn die
russischen Truppen stehen User Userin ie
gibt hier noch einen weiteren Punkt mit
rein schreibt wie bewerten Sie die
derzeitigen verschleißraten
verschleißungsraten der russischen Armee
kommen wir dahin dass Russland im
Oktober keine weiteren Panzer Munition
und so weiter für den Krieg liefern
kann also ich ich habe mir die die orix
Zahlen heute noch mal angeschaut die
abnutzungsquote sowohl bei den Panzern
wie auch bei den gepanzerten
Transportfahrzeugen die ist unverändert
also wir sind nach wie vor auf etwa 4 F
Panzer pro Tag und fünf gepanzerten
Fahrzeugen pro Tag und wir sehen
natürlich auch eine laufende
technologische Verschlechterung auf
Seiten der Russen also es wird zwar noch
Material an die Front geschoben aber es
es wird eben immer älter wir haben heute
ein Video gesehen von insgesamt vier
abgeschossenen Panzern vor
verbor also insofern gehe ich nicht
davon aus dass ich bei der
russischen Produktion oder bei der
artillerieintensität irgendwas geändert
hätte nein also der der Krieg läuft im
Wesen mit dieser mit dieser
abnutzungsstrategie äh weiter und ähm ja
wenn wenn es so lange weitergeht dann
dann kommen die Russen irgendwann in
dieses Szenario dass ich ja schon
mehrfach
mehrfach gepinselt habe in in
verschiedenen Interviews
wo sie einfach nicht mehr fähig sind an
allen Punkten der Front gleichzeitig
stark zu verteidigen wo auch die
Artillerie langsam in die Abnutzung
kommt nicht nur wegen der Munition auch
wegen wegen des Verschleißes
der der Geschützrohre und ich den denke
nein also mit mit jedem Tag den der
Krieg dauert wird er für Russland
logistisch schwieriger jemand
interessiert sich hier das ist Sebastian
Kampf wie das Verhältnis des Nachschubs
Schubs ist wir haben über Russland
gesprochen aber er fragt sich eben
Verhältnis Ukraine versus Russland ja
jetzt müssten sie mir genauer sagen was
sie mit Verhältnis des Nachschubs meinen
sonst kann Sebastian Kampf das auch
gerne noch ein bisschen präzisieren kan
das noch konkretisieren wir geben Ihnen
noch kurz die Chance wir haben noch ich
sag mal gute 5 Minuten dann würde ich
hier noch eine andere Frage stellen
wollen wenn wir auch weiterhin noch beim
Thema Logistik kurz bleiben wollen DAV
dann rasche fragt bei Youtube welche
Rolle spielen die Häfen der Grimm und
der asofküste bei der russischen
Logistik also die die Häfen weniger die
die Krim ist natürlich das logistische
Zentrum der ganzen russischen Operation
und deswegen hat z.B Ben Hodges völlig
recht wenn er immer sagt die Krim ist
das eigentliche das eigentliche Herz der
Operation ja also sie müssen den Russen
klar machen dass die Krim haltbar wird
und deswegen ist jetzt auch das Ziel
dieser Operation natürlich die
Schwarzmeerküste zu erreichen weil
sobald sie das geschafft haben können
Sie Ihre gesamte Artillerie dort
aufstellen und den Russen klar machen
also entweder zieht ihr ab oder ähm oder
wir schießen euch zusammen die
logistische äh Kapazität die kommt aber
vor allem über die Brücke von Kersch ähm
weniger über die Häfen ähm auf den ähm
es ist sind mehr die airbases an der
Küste also theodosia ist ist weniger der
Hafen äh interessant sondern die die
Radare die dort stehen auch die die
Anlagen zur elektronischen Kriegführung
die die ukrainischen fernoperationen
also vor allem mit mit KMS behindindern
und
ähm ja aber wenn wenn wir uns anschauen
die Ukraine hat ja
in den letzten sechs Wochen die
Verbindungen von der Krim auf das
ukrainische Festland ziemlich
erfolgreich zum ersten Mal beschossen
ich denke persönlich sie lässt die
Brücke von Kersch immer noch offen um
den Russen eine rückzugsmöglich it zu
geben weil sie könnte durchaus mit mit
brutaler Gewalt versuchen diese Brücke
zu zerstören und ich denke genau das ist
das Kalkül weil der Krieg dadurch
interessanterweise nicht verlängert
sondern sogar verkürzt wird wenn man den
Russen einfach die Gelegenheit gibt
abzuziehen aber man muss auch sagen da
sind wir noch nicht also wir sind jetzt
in in der Phase wo es darum geht ist der
Krieg für die Russen strategisch
verloren oder nicht und er ist
strategisch verloren sobald die Ukraine
in eine Position kommt zu sagen wir
können die schwarzmküste erreichen wir
können die Krim beschießen also sprich
ihr könnt jetzt hier noch ein Jahr
rumstehen und euch Zusammenschießen
lassen oder ihr könnt es einsehen und
abziehen und
ich habe ja damals in meinem Interview
im März in der Neuen Zürcher Zeitung
gesagt die Lage wird so ein bisschen
sein wie 1944 die Kampfhandlungen werden
noch nicht aufhören wir können auch noch
eine Zeit lang weitergehen aber der
Krieg wird dann strategisch entschieden
sein dazu gleich mehr aber wir wollen
Sebastian Kampf auch noch die
Möglichkeit geben seine Frage hier zu
präzisieren und zwar schreibt er was er
damit meint was ihn interessiert mit
Verhälnis des Nachschubs ist der
nachschchub über die Zeit für beide
Seiten aktuell wird ja für die Ukraine
kein schweres Gerät geliefert das könnte
doch zum Problem für die Ukraine werden
oder also schweres Gerät hat die Ukraine
durchaus also sie hat insgesamt neun
schwere gepanzerte Brigaden die im
Wesentlichen im Rückzugsraum stehen also
nicht an der Front sondern die einfach
warten darauf dass diese Tasche aufgeht
und das ist einfach die Konsequenz aus
diesem einen Vorfall den wir hatten vor
vor als die Gegenoffensive begonnen hat
wo wir da diese abgeschossenen Leo und
Bradleys im Feld gesehen haben also
spricht diese was die Ukraine
ursprünglich versucht hat mit diesen
schweren Brigaden direkt durch die
Stellung oder durch die Minenfelder
durchzugehen das hat nicht funktioniert
weil die Minenfelder und Befestigung
dafür zu dicht sind und jetzt versuchen
sie es eben so also sprich erst diese
Tasche aufzumachen den Russen
nicht mehr die Möglichkeit zu geben Sie
sie zuzumachen die Russen logistisch zu
überdehnen und dann durch diese Tasche
in den Hinterraum vorzustoßen wo die
russ en keine Reserven mehr haben das
und das heißt das kommt also nicht so
sehr auf kontinuierlichen nachflug an
weil die schweren Brigaden die sind
schon da die haben auch
Munition was der der diese
gefechtsführung die wir im Moment sehen
das ist mehr so leicht gepanzerte
Infanterie die sich hier die sich hier
vorarbeitet und natürlich im Hintergrund
die Artillerie die sich duelliert und
und versucht eben möglichst die
russischen Systeme herauszunehmen die im
Moment noch die straßenbewegung
kontrollieren sie haben eben ein
Interview angesprochen was sie der
Züricher Zeitung der neuen Züricher
Zeitung gegeben hatten da wird auch
immer mal wieder Bezug drauf genommen es
gibt hier zwei Fragen die ich zum Ende
mit einem Blick nach vorn zusammenfassen
möchte zum einen fragt sich hier jemand
ob sie immer noch der Meinung sind dass
Russland bis Ende Oktober geschlagen
sein wird und jemand anderes hier Armin
John Kevin schreibt sich was macht sie
so zuversichtlich dass die Ukraine
langfristig den Krieg gewinnen kann ja
ach sie glauben gar nicht wie oft ich
das gefragt werde in letzter Zeit also
bitte ich sage immer an dieser Stelle
zitieren Sie mich korrekt ich habe nicht
gesagt
der Krieg ist aus und Russland
kapituliert ich habe gesagt der Krieg
wird strategisch verloren sein für
Russland im Oktober und warum habe ich
das gesagt weil ich versucht habe sowohl
die logistische abnutzungsrate zu
berechnen als auch mir überlegt habe wo
könnte die Ukraine durchbrechen mit
welcher Geschwindigkeit könnte sie das
tun was bräuchte sie selber an Logistik
dafür ich habe auch oft in meinen
vergangenen Interviews den raumsorisia
Anges und gesagt ich erwarte dort
eigentlich den Durchbruch an die an die
Küste ich denke ich habe immer versucht
in in meinen Analysen eben nicht auf auf
persönliche Meinung oder Stimmungsbilder
oder Emotionen oder keine
Ahnung selbstgeschriebene
Publikationen zu achten sondern mir
einfach anzugucken was in der Realität
passiert und ich würde sagen wenn wenn
ich es insgesamt bewerten bewerten muss
ich stehe immer noch dazu also ich ich
denke das hier ist im Moment das Maximum
der Kraftentfaltung dass wir sehen von
der Gegenoffensive und ähm die
Geschwindigkeit die wir im Moment
beobachten die macht mich eigentlich
ziemlich zuversichtlich also wenn wenn
die Russen eine funktionierende
Verteidigung hätten dann würde eine
solche Tasche sich nicht öffnen dann
könnten sie das mit massiver Gegenwehr
ähm oder mit mobilen Operationen
zurückschlagen also die die allein die
Tatsache dass diese Tasche sich öffnet
das zeigt mir einfach dass die
russischen Verbände entweder immer
schlechter verlegungsfähig sind oder
einfach nicht mehr ihre maximale
Kampfkraft haben und wenn das so ist
dann ist das jetzt vielleicht der Punkt
ähm wo wo der Wendepunkt ähm der ganzen
Operation einsetzt das heißt wo die
russischen Kräfte das Maximum ihrer
Kraftentfaltung überschritten haben die
Russen haben die Initiative verloren
haben sich deswegen eingegraben und
jetzt kommt der Punkt wo die Ukraine in
der Lage ist das Maximum ihrer Kräfte zu
entfalten und ähm wenn das stärker ist
als das was die Russen noch zu bieten
haben ähm dann ist das für die die
Russen nur noch ein Rückzugsgefecht
natürlich das das geht nicht von heute
auf morgen ja und sicher sind die
Kampfhandlungen im Oktober nicht vorbei
aber ich denke schon dass jetzt in in
den nächsten Wochen die strategische
Entscheidung in diesem Krieg also
zumindest was die Südfront angeht und
was die beschussmöglichkeit auf die Krim
angeht dass die Fallen wirden das schöne
ist an unserer Sendung wenn es besonders
spannend ist können wir ja sogar noch
ein Hauch länger werden mir sind zwei
Sachen im Stream noch aufgefallen die
möchte ich Ihnen gerne noch stellen und
zwar gibt's hier eine Frage von Michael
Müller den hatten wir am Anfang auch
schon mal bei Youtube der sagt sich und
das passt auch wieder gut zum Anfang der
Sendung wie verändert dieser massive
drohneneinsatz an der Front die
klassische Strategie und
Taktik in vielerlei Hinsicht die die
klassische Strategie und Taktik geht
einfach davon aus dass sie durch
Aufklärung vieles beobachten können geht
davon aus dass sie natürlich sich der
Bedrohung aus der Luft bewusst sind und
entsprechend
Abwehrmaßnahmen einleiten
könneni Manuals oder oder Hand Bücher
wie wie Taktik gemacht wird gehen nicht
davon aus
dass sie mikrodrohnen haben die sie
beobachten oder dass sie billig drohen
haben die einfach ihr Radar unterfliegen
oder gar nicht sichtbar sind dass sie
loudering Munition haben die einfach von
hinten in ihren Panzer reinfliegt ohne
dass sie das bemerken und sie plötzlich
rausnimmt also ich denke die die meisten
field Manuals die wir so haben die
werden nach diesem Krieg neu geschrieben
werden müssen und ich denke die Ukraine
hat hat schon so viele militärische
Innovationen eingeführt wo wo selbst
heute schon die us-generä sagen wir wir
hätten sowas gar nicht machen können
weil wir so sehr in unserem eigenen
taktischen denken stecken ähm ich ich
denke man man wird das völlig neu
bewerten müssen also dieser Krieg ist
natürlich auch so kriegshistorisch etwas
völlig Neues abgesehen davon natürlich
auch von der Social Media Komponente
also dass dass Analysten wie ich heute
in der Lage sind eigentlich in Echtzeit
den Krieg zu beobachten ähm dass so der
der klassische wissensvorteil von
Geheimdiensten ziemlich ziemlich
zusammengeschrumpft ist ähm das sind
alles Dinge ähm die die wirklich
erstmalig so in der Kriegsgeschichte
aufgetrochen und zum Ende würde ich
gerne noch einen Kommentar mit einer
Frage kombinieren Murat schreibt kann es
sein dass wir wieder die Russen
unterschätzen so oft wurde gesagt jetzt
jetzt sind die Russen erledigt jetzt
beißen sich die Ukrainer an der
Verteidigung die Zähne aus und Abdullah
chelik fragt dazu aber auch wenn die
Russen strategisch verlieren sollten was
passiert danach mm also zunächst mal ähm
Thema Überschätzung der Russen da würde
ich Ihnen vorschlagen schauen Sie doch
einfach die Geschichte dieses Krieges an
ja also zunächst mal die dilettantische
Operationsführung in den ersten Tagen
des Krieges äh die riesige Kolonne die
vor Kiev stand und stecken blieb die
logistischen Probleme äh die Korruption
ähm die die Unmöglichkeit zu
geschlossener Operationsführung die
Unmöglichkeit äh gefechter verbundenen
Waffen zu führen dann die rakov isium
Operation diletantische
frontverteidigung hinten steht nichts
die Ukraine rollt einfach den ganzen
Raum auf ähm die Operation die rakov
zurück gewonnen hat ähm die Operation
jetzt also verstehen sie das das ist was
was sie verstehen müssen ist dass das
Russland von heute ist nicht die
Sowjetunion und die russische Armee ist
nicht
die sowjetische Rote Armee das war was
völlig anderes und die hatte eine völlig
andere Kampfkraft das hier ist äh wie
soll ich sagen der korrupte und
heruntergewirtschaftete Rest aber das
können sie nicht mehr vergleichen mit
mit Bildern die sie vielleicht noch vom
Kalten Krieg ähm oder oder vom Zweiten
Weltkrieg im im Kopf haben also
insofern es ist natürlich Ziel der
russischen Propaganda Russland
darzustellen als mächtig unbesiegbar und
so weiter aber wie gesagt ich kann immer
nur wieder sagen studieren Sie die
Fakten studieren Sie die Logistik
schauen Sie sich an was tatsächlich
passiert
und und vielleicht lesen sie lesen Sie
weniger Zeitung und onlinemien sondern
schauen Sie auf die Analysten die
tatsächlich diese Sachen in Karten
einzeichnen und
berechnen und und Sie bekommen so ein
objektiveres Bild der Lage als wenn es
von irgendwelchen Medien vorgefiltert
ist ja und dann die Frage was heißt was
heißt strategisch verloren na ja
strategisch verloren heißt für die
Russen eben ähm die Entscheidung zu
treffen eigentlich wie das
nationalsozialistische Deutschland 1944
also gestehe ich mir jetzt ein dass ich
zwar weiter kämpfen kann aber ähm dass
das keinen Unterschied mehr macht das
ist nur noch eine Frage der Zeit ist
oder sage ich okay
ähm ich ziehe ab und und überlege mir
irgendein narrativ dass ich zu Hause
verkaufen kann ähm wo wo womit das doch
irgendeinen Sinn hatte so nach dem Motto
ja wir haben jetzt war alle Nazis in der
Ukraine getötet oder na ja wir mussten
gegen die ganze NATO kämpfen das konnten
wir nicht gewinnen das ist natürlich
alles humbur und und Propaganda aber in
Russland selber könnte Putin das
durchaus so verkaufen ich denke das sind
mehr Fragen für Russland als als für die
Ukraine
für die Ukraine kommt jetzt tatsächlich
darauf an diese Bewegung zu Ende zu
führen sagt Militärexperte Markus Kol
vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit heute Abend
und bis zum nächsten Mal gerne schönen
Abend
noch und auch vielen Dank an Euch für
Eure Fragen für eure regge Teilnahme
viele Kommentare habe ich gelesen ich
hoffe ich konnte auch viele Fragen hier
mit reinbringen in den Stream und wir
sagen für heute vielen Dank schönes
Wochenende gerne bis zum nächsten mal
Danke vom gesamten Team bis dahin
tschüss